في حقيقه الواقع هنالك تضارب بالمعلومات
الاعلاميه عن المكان الذي تم الانتشار فيه
ولكن نحن نبحث في داخل المدينه ووصلنا الى
هذه المنطقه وتحديدا الى هذه البنايه التي
يظن بحسب المشرفين على هذه البنايه ان
هنالك شخص لا زال حي تحت الالقاب في هذه
البنايه ولذلك كما تشاهد معي هذه الورشه
الكامله القائمه بحد ذاتها مئات او عشرات
عشرات الى مئه تقريبا من الدفاع المدني
ومن المتطوعين ومن الخبراء الذين وصلوا
الى هنا ومن ايضا سيارات الدفاع المدني
والسيارات ايضا الاسعاف وصلوا الى هذه
المنطقه
سالناهم ماذا يجري كان الجواب يظن او
يعتقدوا لديهم ان هناك لا يزال شخص
لذلك كان هذا الجهد الذي تراه معي مباشره
على الهواء من الجرافات وايضا من العمال
الذين بطبيعه الحال يعملون بوتيره متواصله
منذ ثلاثه ساعات كان هنالك وضع منذ ساعه
تقريبا تقطعت فيه عمليات العمل الى صمت ما
بين النصف ساعه والنصف الاخر وهذه مساله
تتبع وتمارس عاده حتى يكون هنالك تواصل
بينهم وبين الشخص تطفئ كل هذه الايه
الالات وهذا ما حصل بالفعل حتى اننا نحن
الان عن الهواء مباشره لربما ايضا يطلبون
مننا ان نصمت يسود الهدوء كل المكان ثم
بعد ذلك يبداون العمل من جديد تقريبا
هي للمره الثانيه
بخلال نصف ساعه هذه المساله نفذت على
الارض
مما يدلل الى ان هنالك امل في ان تعثر فرق
الانقاذ على هذا الحي اما بالنسبه والعوده
العوده معك للسؤال عن المراه المسنه لاكن
موضوعيا معك نقوم بجهد لمعرفه المكان الذي
تم تم فيه عمليه الانتشار ونحن قمنا بجوله
منذ حوالي نصف ساعه ونقوم داخل هذا الحي
والى احياء اخرى علنا نوفق بذلك المكان
ولكن ايضا يعني محمود فقط اشير لك انه قبل
قليل
بعض الانباء على يعني مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي اشارت الى انه السيده موجوده
كانت في حطام مبنى يسمى ميرفي للوحدات
السكنيه لا نعرف اذا كان يمكن تحديد هذا
المكان تحديدا لكن بالعوده الى من يشاهد
الان يعني هناك مجرفات تقوم ممكن مع كله
جائز وممكن الان الجرافات تقوم
بازاله الركام وهناك عدد كبير يعني عاده
هذا العدد الكبير ووجود سيارات الاسعاف
الى جانب هذه الاليات هل يشير الى وجود
يعني ناجين تحت الانقاض وام انه عاده ما
تعمل فرق الاغاثه والانقاذ بوجود سيارات
الاسعاف هل يتم استدعائها في حال هناك
شكوك بوجود احياء ام انها دائما تكون
موجوده الى جانب فرق الانقاذ
عزيزي هذه الصوره هي يجوز او يصح بها
القول انها كانت في الايام الاولى
لزلتال وكانت كل هذه الورش على هذه الحاله
ولكن الان في هذا الشارع الذي نحن به
وعلامه امتداد خمسه الى سته كيلو متر كل
الجرافات هي مطفئه وكل الاعمال هي متوقفه
ما عدا هذه الورشه وهذه البنايه التي كما
نشاهدها نحن ذهبنا اليهم بالسؤال وخاصه
لعمال الانقاذ الذين يقفون على جانب
الطريق كان الجواب انهم يعتقدون ان هنالك
شخص لا يزال حي وحتى هذه الساعه وهم وصلوا
الى هذه المساله عبر التقنيات لديهم لذلك
وصلت سيارات الاسعاف الى هذه البقعه مع
ممرضين وممرضات وشاهدنا كيف انهم يجهزون
بعض المعدات ولكن هذه
المساله دائما كنا نلتقي بها او كان الجو
السائد مع الامل والرجاء دائما في كل
الورش ننتظر في بعضها من يخرج حيا وفي بعض
الاخر للاسف من يخرج لكن